so last week I post a question how could
we improve our current voting system we
have an American today I'll be sharing
with you some of my ideas
I'm Patrick may they be your host of
value 10 min weekend today we have the
tough task of making a subject like
voting exciting with some tells me we're
going to be able to pull it off and by
the way 12 my Red Sox fans out there
better love in New Jersey I'm weren't
I'm a die-hard babe ruth fan this as a
babe route jersey i collect this cards
and today i wanted to wear babe ruth
jersey but let's get right into it i'll
share with you my this you in a minute
and i think voting is a very very
important subject when you look at some
of the numbers why people are voting
less than 2000 a presidential election
we had 61.6 percent of eligible voters
show up and in 2012 we had 58.2 % sure
what which is dropped by roughly three
percent and you know the subject of
voting keeps coming up and i said we
need to do an episode on it and put some
ideas together now put these ideas for a
while but today I'll presented to you
because look we've had a lot of people
that are fought very hard whether it's
to get african-american with civil
rights to be able to vote or women's
rights we've come along such a long way
but but I think we can even improve it
even more today than before so let me
get right into it let me get right into
it the program i'm going to be talking
to you about is called earning the right
to vote earning the right to vote the
reason why it's called earning the right
to vote I'm an immigrant I came here
from Iran to America America was willing
to open the doors and allow our family
to come here in Iran we didn't have
freedom of religion freedom of assembly
freedom of speech freedom of many many
things free enterprise and so in America
they offer that to us but I didn't come
and feeling entitled to all of it I felt
as an immigrant I had to give back and
earn the freedom that America gave me so
the program is called earning the right
to the first one point number one if you
paid a thousand dollars in income taxes
the prior year you get one vote so what
if somebody pays ten thousand dollars in
income taxes you get 10 votes what if
somebody pays a hundred thousand dollars
in income taxes you get 100 votes well
you may say Pat that's not fair the
people who pay more taxes get more votes
I simply took the system on how public
corporations or companies who have
outstanding shareholders and outstanding
shares on the system they use and this
is how it works a company could have 1
million outstanding share
but only a hundred people on the 101
million outstanding shares and the way
they allow to vote is not based on the
100 shareholders if one person owns only
one share versus a person owns a hundred
thousand shares which one has more to
say more of a voice for this company
obviously the person that has 100,000
shares and I feel our voting system
should be the same exact way if you
contribute to society more you ought to
have more of a voice on what we should
do with our voting system versus
somebody who does not and if you want to
have more of a voice you ought to pay a
little bit more into the income taxes
that's my ID on point number one and it
would be a salary cap with a hundred
shares 100 vote so you can't go above
100 votes kind of like how NFL has a
salary cap that's the way i will put out
a hundred votes and the age part with
this it has nothing to do with 18 years
old 21 years old 25 years old 30 years
old if a 16 year old kid who worked at
baskin-robbins last year and he made 15
thousand dollars and he paid two
thousand dollars in income taxes he
ought to have two boats himself versus a
23 year old kid who's completely healthy
is not disabled doesn't want to get a
job wants to stay at home he doesn't
want to go to college I would rather
hear from the 16 year old kid who's
paying income taxes and contributing to
society then a 23 year old kid that is
undecided wants to stay home family pays
for all his bills he does want to give
back to society I'd rather hear from the
16 year old point number two of the
ideas have in place if you serve the
military whether you pay any taxes or
not you get a vote but you need to
complete boot camp and AIT advanced
individual training I think military's a
good thing for a lot of our younger boys
to go into because the disciplines them
teaches us a lot about independence
toughness fight freedom on or a lot of
good things I think it'll do a lot of
good things for the country period but
if somebody in a military paid fifteen
thousand dollars in taxes he would get
15 votes because his numbers would still
accumulate and go higher but if somebody
meant to the military and didn't pay any
taxes you're still getting one vote
because you serve the military point
number three public service police
officers firefighters park ranger
Highway Patrol of a few other names on
this list here they put their lives on
the line similar to military if your
will
to put your life on the line and go
fight fires while your wife is at home
wondering what's going to happen to you
got two little ones you want to put your
life on the line for me I mean you you
have more than earned the right to vote
same with police officers and so you get
an additional boat if you are serving
for public service and they're putting
your life on the line you absolutely get
the right to vote as well because of
what you're doing number for job
creators nonprofit or profit if you
create a job that pays a hundred and
twenty thousand dollars over a four-year
period income so if you hired somebody
and they make forty thousand dollars
here and there with you for three years
you pay them 120 thousand dollars you
get one vote per job you created for our
economy one vote per job you created for
the economy and the limit on that is
also 100 votes if you created a hundred
jobs you have a hundred votes to to vote
for any kind of things that we're coming
out with point number five retired
individual that's paid over ten thousand
dollars and life taxes they
automatically get to vote because
they've already put into the economy
that put into the to the marketplace
that put into our country to contribute
to society so they get a vote no matter
what the number is ten thousand dollars
number six anyone with a four-year
degree whether you have paid into taxes
or not if you're willing to stay
discipline go to school get educated you
ought to get a vote and for a master's
degree two votes and for PhD three votes
so if you have a bachelors if you have a
master's any have PhD you ought to be
able to have three votes because you
have discipline yourself and gone out
there and finish the education more than
some of the rest of us and we want to
hear from you more because you're
wanting to put your head down and read
the books and educate yourself I think
we need more people to go out and
educate themselves like the people stay
disciplined to get their four-year
degree eight your degree in their PhDs
and obviously this whole thing would be
needing to have an ID to go out there
and vote but we know who you are
verified that we knew who you're when
you're voting and this is how can look
like if somebody makes sixty thousand
dollars last year they pay ten thousand
dollars in taxes that's ten votes if
that person also has a bachelor's degree
and a master's degree they get two
additional both if they served in a
military before
an additional vote that person could
have realistically 13 votes to vote for
an election because of how much they've
contributed to society but this is the
disclaimer at the end what it has to do
with illegal immigrants because we have
this whole debate with amnesty and I've
been interviewed on this before on what
do we do with illegal immigrants because
so many times people say all illegal
immigrants you know they ran across the
board room we need to do this and we
need to do that honestly if I'm a father
and if I'm living in a country where I
see it's not the best thing for my kids
or if I see what's taking place in Iran
or mex score any of that stuff and I've
gotta prove I'm responsible for my kid I
would go across the border to come to
America to provide a better life for my
kids wouldn't you think about that for a
moment if you look at immigration the
whole purpose of immigration is to bring
the best talent in the world to our
country we are leading in immigration
because the best talent from China from
Europe from everywhere they are still
wanting to come to America it's not as a
head of a lead as we used to have at one
point right now it's dropped a little
bit but we bring the best talent so we
have 11.7 million illegal immigrants
living in America roughly 400,000 of
them were deported last year and out of
that 11.7 million of illegal immigrants
they paid a little shy of 11 billion
dollars in taxes last year so what do we
do with the folks who are illegal
immigrant living in America this is my
opinion these are my ideas I think if
one is an illegal immigrant but they did
any one of these things we talked about
if they went out and they actually paid
a thousand dollars in income taxes
whether it's on a tax ID number if they
went out there and actually serve the
military willing to serve the military
they're willing to go out and serve the
military they're willing to become cops
police officers they're qualified
they're willing to go out and create
jobs they're willing to go out there and
get a degree and get educated if they're
willing to do these things I say we need
to allow and give them the right to go
out there and and and take a quiz
because they need they need to take a
test to know the history of America who
the present and a certain things that I
need to know about but I think their
votes oughta count as well for what they
do to society to play a very very
important role there's no reason why we
should not have illegal immigrants being
able to vote as well there are more
people that are illegal immigrants that
are contributing more to society than
somebody
was a legal immigrant but they're not
contributed society why not let them be
heard as well if they're willing to earn
the right to vote by contributing to
society so what we did is we went to the
streets and we went on cup of college
campuses you'll see a logo in one of the
college campuses we went on and ask
questions from different people on what
they thought about some of these
subjects such as voting in politics and
here's some of the answers we got all
right so first question is how would you
improve the current voting system in the
United States I was going to say maybe
more parties but probably complicate
things they will take too long probably
for things what i would do is make the
boat that the people put out when they
go to the booster boat they got the one
that counts not the one that takes place
behind closed doors when it gets back
into the officers in the end it's just a
popular vote what really matters is the
electoral vote put more polling stations
in different areas encourage more people
to vote I would make it more convenient
for people to vote by decreasing the
super PACs probably better inform people
encourage more younger people to do it
because I know that like people like me
don't really want to they're too lazy or
they don't know how to even though it's
really easy prefer for there to be
better access to voting booths as far as
politically you know you got the
Republicans that the Democrats I think
they play for the same team and I don't
think voting really changes anything do
you think illegal immigrants who pay
taxes should be allowed to vote uh yes I
think they're people and they matter so
yes they should absolutely be allowed to
vote they pay doctors in yeah when you
become a citizen then you can vote
you're a taxpayer you've been here for a
while doesn't matter if you're illegal
or not you know if you call America your
home you know your voice vote does count
no I think if they pay taxes
and they're not exploiting the
government they should be able to go yes
I think that since they can trip to the
government they should have that that
right I feel like this shouldn't be able
to vote unless they're already in the
process of trying to become a legal
citizen yes definitely everyone
complained about them but then there's
certain jobs like at restaurants or like
you know like in the fields and all of
that like if most of those jobs are done
by illegal immigrants so they didn't do
it then there would be like a big chaos
and they have a great contribution to
the economy in society and you know
after other is trying to incorporate
themselves into it so they should I
think you have to be a citizen I think
you have to do the whole process to
become a citizen do everything that
there is or be a son was born here to be
a citizen if they're not going to be
part of our part of our system they're
not going to be part of our land part of
us there's no reason why they should
have anything to say about it they come
over to vision next one is should 16
year olds be allowed to vote if they
work and pay taxes no they're [ __ ] I
have kids just cuz they can work at pay
taxes doesn't mean that they have the
education and you know the time real
life the fact that they're paying taxes
should give them a right to vote just
because a lot of voting what they vote
on has to do with what their money is
being used for with those taxes so I
don't see why they shouldn't have that
right there's a tough one some 16 year
olds are very mature some art even
though that they're working I don't know
if I trust necessarily 16 year olds
opinion but 18 and even 21 is probably
not any difference so that's a hard one
they pay taxes so they contribute to the
government I think that you should have
that privilege I think anybody pays
taxes ought to be allowed to vote yes
and no I think it depends on the person
it's more of AI think I'm a charity
thing they're contributing to the
economy they're doing you know
productive citizens that deserve the
right to voice their opinions and at
least it should be able to vote no they
don't they don't they don't have the
responsibilities I don't think so i
think because they don't know that much
they are learning certain things in
school but they'd probably just go with
whoever their parents about with yes I
so they were can pay taxes I don't think
age should really determine someone's
maturity no I I don't think it the age
is an issue I think you have to be well
informed but if Justin Bieber ever ran
for politics would you vote for him
definitely not absolutely not that would
depend on what he has to say you know
all politicians are [ __ ] pretty much
so they'd have to see what he have to
say now no but you know 40 years these
are probably a completely different man
who's that who justin bieber never room
definitely that's like a hundred percent
don't even go there all these things i
heard an internet and all that stuff I
don't think it would be a good idea no
no way after everything he's been doing
he's just a stupid teenage kid who
doesn't know what he's doing if you
could choose any celebrity to run for
politics who would you want to see do
that Brad Pitt just because partly
because I just like to see him on TV
more often doing all his folks feel you
may be Brad Pitt I guess it makes a lot
of sense right Brad Pitt running for
politics people with both form because
we would love to see more on TV I
thought I was pretty interesting comment
she gave but for the most part a lot of
good commentary there on what people
talked about so here's what I'd like to
do you heard my ideas these are my ideas
I would like to hear your ideas and I
don't necessarily I'm expecting you to
agree with everything I talked about or
disagreed everything I talked about if
you do disagree i'd love to hear what
you would do to improve some of the
systems or the voting system that we
have in America and because one thing I
know for a fact we the people together
can do some incredible things we've been
able to build this incredible nation
here and if we continue to keep fighting
to improve we can even take you to a
whole different level we've never ever
been before in the United States of
America please be sure to subscribe
maybe share this video with other people
and comment on the body
you
you